malgré une volonté affichée d'avancer
ensemble entre bruxelles et londres
les divergences subsistent michel
barnier négociateur en chef de l'union
européenne sur le bric site n'a pas
hésité à pointer du doigt le royaume uni
selon lui en réaffirmant sa volonté de
ne pas prolonger la période de
transition
le pays ne s'est pas engagé sérieusement
et a ainsi ralenti les négociations en
cours de uk quand une houston 6 le
royaume uni continuent d'insister sur un
certain nombre d'accords distincts
chacun ayant ses propres modalités de
gouvernance qui schlitte cela entraîne
des doubles emplois et d inefficacité
ainsi qu'un manque de transparence dans
l'application et la mise en oeuvre du
partenariat
ce qui n'est dans l'intérêt de personne
et nobody's interest uk chausse faut le
royaume uni a choisi d'être un pays
tiers c'est son choix
ce sont les conséquences à fait
conséquents en sus et puis le note
between ne sera pas traité comme un état
membre
nous devons prendre ce fait comme point
de départ à ouattara porte des
accusations qui ne sont pas restées sans
réponse dans un communiqué ding ning
street explique ce ralentissement dans
les négociations en raison d'importantes
divergences de principe pour londres
bruxelles ne respecte pas ses
engagements passés et propose un accord
bien inférieurs à ceux signés
précédemment avec d'autres états nous
devons maintenant avancer d'une manière
constructive
le royaume uni reste déterminée à
trouver un compromis avec pour base un
accord de libre échange
l'un des principaux points de blocage la
question sensible de la pêche à laquelle
les britanniques n'ont toujours pas
proposé de solution
reste à savoir si les négociations
prendront un autre tournant lors des
deux autres sessions prévues pour les
semaine du 11 mai et du 1er juin
prochain